the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 News Now or next our Media
Group with these protests which are
leading to riots one tragedy is only
leading to another tonight on politics
now black lives matter protests peaceful
rallies give way to clashes in the
shooting of a metro police officer we
hear more from Sheriff Joe Lombardo plus
we're gonna be conscientious in our
decision-making process as to whether we
should file charges
District Attorney Steve Wolfson tells us
how those arrested during protests will
be prosecuted and Tuesday is primary day
what you need to know about this
election
from 8:00 news now this is politics now
and we do start with the June primary
election which is just a few days away
thank you for joining us I'm John Lange
look if you have not sent in your mail
ballot just yet it needs to be
postmarked by Tuesday June 9th there are
30 ballot drop-off locations across
Clark County and drop-off locations open
this weekend and on Monday as well on
Election Day there will be three
in-person locations for voting that will
partially be done to allow same-day
registration now at those in-person
locations the setup will be different
than what you might be used to there are
no voting machines election workers will
print out your mail-in ballot and hand
it to you then you fill it out you sign
it and you hand it right back there is a
separate area set up for same-day
registration that will also be a hand
the paper that they will also hand the
paper to you and then you hand it back
and that's how it's set up if you're
registered on Election Day you do need
identification this is all because of
the corona virus of course for more than
a week people have flooded the streets
of the cities of the United States they
are protesting the death of George Floyd
an unarmed black man who died in the
custody of Minneapolis police here in
Las Vegas
near nightly protests organized by black
lives matter have started out peaceful
thousands of marched in downtown Las
Vegas and on the Las Vegas Strip despite
the strong desire for those protests to
stay peaceful there were some instances
of vandalism tear gas being used and
arrests law enforcement says outsiders
are causing this violence and that
includes the shooting of metro police
officer Shane McGill Onis earlier this
week right now he is on life support
this is sad night for lb MPD family in a
tragic night for our community with
these protests which are leading to
riots one tragedy is only leading to
another officer Michael Onis was shot
during that protest outside of Circus
Circus Monday night fellow officers
public officials and community members
are still supporting him
Nicole Onis has been on the Metro police
force for four years his parents and
brother are Metro officers as well the
i-team's Vanessa Murphy asked Clark
County District Attorney Steve Wolfson
about how protesters arrested for
vandalism will be prosecuted everyone
supports a citizen's right to express
themselves their right to assemble the
right to protest we encourage it it's
good it's a good thing to have the
ability to express oneself this is not a
perfect society we live in and this
freedom of expression if done within the
bounds of the law if done peacefully can
help us all to understand and make
improvements however there's a line and
when a person crosses over from a
peaceful expression into violence
whether it be throwing rocks throwing
bottles shooting guns or otherwise
breaking the law we have to enforce that
law and that's what we do so those cases
will be reviewed on a case-by-case basis
the misdemeanor cases the vast majority
if not all of them are out of custody
and we have court return dates in about
60 days so we're going to be
conscientious in our decision making
process as to whether we should file
charges and what charges should be filed
and against whom there have been several
hundred arrests made during the protests
in Las Vegas Nevada Governor Steve
systolic showed support for the peaceful
protests on his YouTube page but as you
protest know that I see you and I'm
listening please be safe out there to
our law enforcement officers I ask that
you be patient compassionate and
sympathetic with our fellow Nevadans
governor has his CELAC went on to say
he's going to hold meaningful
conversations over the upcoming months
with lawmakers and he also said he looks
forward to signing legislation next
session based on the outcome with some
of those discussions with the community
as well
Assembly Speaker Jason Frierson also
said lawmakers would look at
de-escalation implicit bias training and
other similar policies for law
enforcement now the protests nationwide
have centered around police use of force
specifically against the
african-american community earlier this
week I spoke with UNLV assistant
professor of African
American Studies Tyler Perry we
discussed pent-up frustration in the
african-american community and what he
thinks change would look like another
difference and I don't know if this is a
is a indicative of the actual case of
mr. Floyd or if it's a sign of a change
in the community is seeing in some
cities law enforcement joining the
protest kneeling with them coming out
against the police actions in
Minneapolis is that a broader sign that
there there is change taking place or is
that specific because the video is so
yeah I mean there's there's probably
multiple conclusions one could come to
and I think maybe a few things can be
true at the same time I mean on the one
hand if you look at the tweets from
various protesters and try to peel back
the many thousands that have that have
come across is that they've suggested
that the police did kneel initially but
then they did start dispersing the crowd
and what was interpreted as a violent
manner and so my my opinion here is that
I think that there are probably many
police officers that are sympathetic if
not overly supportive of the actual
protests but they are trapped within a
system that's predicated upon I guess
Brotherhood of a fraternity that you
have to support police officers your
fellow police officers before anyone
else and so it makes them difficult to
actually support it consistently I mean
you might kneel for an hour but then you
are arresting or beating people up who
you see or you interpret as causing a
disturbance is there a frustration in
the african-american community that
nothing's changed what half things or
have things changed and this group sang
about have things changed and this is an
outlier okay so I would say that the
frustration stems from the fact that
change only appears to have happened in
the LVN PD to the extent that it has
because people had leveled complaints
against it I mean if people have been
silenced and just allowed police to
continually brutalize them then the
police would have just kept doing it and
then and this was pretty consistent
throughout the nineteen nineties and
into the early 2000s it seems that the
significant change I mean I'm from here
I'm from Las Vegas originally and I'm
old enough to remember when Stanley
Gibson was was murdered essentially in
the parking lot
Gulf War veteran african-american men
who had mental health issues and
essentially with an ar-15 he was gunned
down and it took that for a lot of the
investigations to really commence and so
the frustration is is why does it take
black trauma and murder to get people to
wake up to the problems of police
brutality there's more of that interview
at 8 News now.com and we're going to
have more on what is happening in
Congress to tackle police use of force
issues a little bit later on in the
program the other big news in Las Vegas
this week casinos are now open for
business that's statewide at the stroke
of midnight on Thursday gambling
reopened
so that was the scene at the D on
Fremont Street marking the end two and a
half months of closure designed to try
and stop the spread of the corona virus
would you see their bartenders go-go
dancers are wearing face shields and
masks inside though it appeared a lot of
people kind of forgot about social
distancing so we open it up life it's
kind of a strange time right everything
shut down and we wanted to come in to
support all the local people that make
the economy so strong the casinos
themselves have plenty of social
distancing rules and regulations in
place including employees having to our
masks and personal protective equipment
to protect themselves many strip casinos
opened later on Thursday morning visitor
is over at the Bellagio welcomed with a
standing ovation
applause and cheers while some guests
just checked right in others went
straight to the casino floor resorts are
eliminating the number of people that
can be at the table games the slot
machines are also separated for social
distancing and it's a little dead but
hopefully this weekend that pickup we've
booked sank three times trying to be
here for the reopening and obviously it
got postponed each time so we're happy
to actually be here now on that first
day Thursday the sidewalks weren't
particularly busy during the day some
people were strolling by the Bellagio
fountains though just to see it as the
resort's reopen Nevada is grappling not
only with the coronavirus but also the
highest unemployment in the nation take
a look at this year Las Vegas has the
highest unemployment rate of any
metropolitan area in the country thirty
three and a half percent for April 2nd
place Detroit that metropolitan area 24%
Cleveland 23 percent unemployment
preparing for an all-male in primary
coming up next on politics now we'll
break down what Election Day will look
like and take a look at how turnout has
been so far and pulling Americans
attitudes about the George Floyd case
and race relations in America
you
[Music]
welcome back to politics now
let's talk about Tuesday's upcoming
election more than a quarter of a
million Nevadans have already voted in
the June 9th primary though through
Wednesday 276,000 456 Nevadans returned
their mail-in ballots you can see the
numbers here on your screen 636 people
voted in person that puts turnout at
about 17% of active registered voters
that seems like it's pretty much on
track or on par with other years
recently so far compared with the
previous couple of elections and because
of the different nature though it's hard
to tell for sure but the turnout was 23%
in 2018 as you see right there and 19%
in 2016
both of those elections had Senate or
governor races in them as well which is
why it's a little different than now so
far 43% of the people who have taken
part in this election are registered
Democrats 41% are registered Republicans
and the Republican numbers are bolstered
by turnout higher than 30% in four rural
counties Clark counties had turnout at
about 15 percent you can see the numbers
here on your screen
Democrats have an advantage though of
the more than 156,000 ballots returned
in Clark County 76,000 or so are
Democrats 54,000 registered Republican
voters in the primary the Republican
National Committee has sued Clark County
for public records showing how it
reached to deal with Democrats over this
mail-in primary election Clark County
made two concessions after Democrats
sued them they would open to more
same-day voter locations for a total of
two and they would also mail ballots to
the 200,000 inactive registered voters
Republicans call this a shady backroom
deal Democrats also have a pending
lawsuit neither one of those will put a
stop to the primary election however on
Tuesday we're going to have complete
coverage of election day all day long
we'll have special coverage at 7 o'clock
online at 8 News now.com and at 8
o'clock right here on channel 8
we'll break down the early numbers
however Clark County is doing one
numbered dump so we're not gonna have
the final numbers actually until June
16th debating police reform
this injustice is not the case of a few
bad cops but a broken police system next
on politics now the bills being proposed
in Congress right now and our own
Alexandra Limon tells us if they have
any chance of passing and our polling on
race relations in America politics now
you
[Music]
you're watching
new insight on how Americans are
responding to the nationwide black lives
matter protests Joe Khalil from our
Washington DC bureau shows us how the
public views race relations protests and
the president after days of protest
following the death of George Floyd more
than half of Americans say race
relations haven't improved since the
1960s
was very surprising to see that a
majority of people think that they're
either the same or worse that's
according to the next star Emerson
College poll released Wednesday
Spencer Kimball polling director says
the poll shows clear signs of a divided
nation only 43 percent of the country
said that they trust the police those
are the people that we train our
children to go speak to in case of a
problem that's something I think we have
to address as a society almost 46
percent of those polled approve of the
protests while nearly 38 percent
disapproved and unprecedent Trump's
handling of the situation about 47
percent of Americans don't approve
compared to about 36 percent who support
how the president responded to the death
of George Floyd although Kimball says
the president's response hasn't impacted
his overall approval numbers voters may
be perturbed by some of his actions and
activities but at the end of the day
when they have to cast their ballot it
may still vote for him but there were a
few points on which the vast majority of
Americans agreed about 90 percent of
people say the officer who killed George
Floyd should be prosecuted for it it
cuts by party by race by age by religion
everybody is in agreement that what the
officer did was wrong Kable says if
Americans are looking for a reason to be
hopeful a majority of respondents say
they believe race relations will improve
in the future in Washington I'm Joe
Khalil Congress members say they are
working on federal reforms to the
American policing system to ensure
justice for George Floyd and all
Americans of color our Washington DC
correspondent Alexandra Limon reports
that some lawmakers are pushing to pass
bills on police brutality and racial
profiling in the coming weeks some
lawmakers say now is the time for
sweeping reform when it comes to police
brutality and use of force George
was the latest in a terrible history of
modern-day lynchings
where Americans are being killed simply
for the color of their skin
leaders from the black Hispanic Native
American and Asian Pacific American
caucuses are demanding accountability
for the death of George Floyd Democrats
are pushing a resolution to condemn
police brutality racial profiling and
excessive use of force by police and
Texas congressman Joaquin Castro says
they want more changes another proposal
would require state and local
governments to track police use of force
and report it to the Justice Department
the data would be made public Democrats
say they believe the massive nationwide
public call for change will lead to
support from Republicans who have also
been vocal about Floyd's death we need
to work to ensure that what happened
last Monday in Minneapolis never happens
again
and that the perpetrators of crimes like
this one are held accountable California
representative Karen bass chair of the
black caucus says reforms should have
real teeth Democrats hope to tackle the
bills this month in Washington Alexandra
Limon in addition to the proposals that
you just mentioned are there some other
items that Democrats hope to tackle on
Capitol Hill related in response to the
George Floyd his death yeah definitely
Democrats feel that they really need to
seize this moment and it kind of you
know use that public call for change
that we've seen all around the country
so one additional piece of proposed
legislation for example would ban the
transfer of US military equipment to
police departments around the country
Democrats say that none of the streets
around the country Main Street around
the country are not battlegrounds
therefore there's no reason for these
police departments to have and use that
military equipment how
that's gonna be one of the tougher
pieces of legislation to get through the
US Senate which is controlled by
Republicans because we've seen Democrats
make pretty much that exact same
argument for beginning the sale of
assault style rifles to the general
public
and it just hasn't worked so far there's
also that a timeline here you get the
4th of July holiday on the horizon here
there's a sense I imagine a Democrats
kind of want to try and tackle some of
these issues now while the issue is so
much at the forefront of the American
public is there a chance this is
actually going to get to that level in
time and that's exactly right in fact
Democrats have pin mark that fourth of
July deadline has to the fact that they
want to pass these bills and legislation
before that day and it might be possible
to get some of these through the US
House by that deadline however getting
it any package and bill through the US
Senate by the 4th of July is gonna be
extremely tough first of all because
it's unclear whether Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell would actually
call any of these bills to the floor for
a vote in the Senate at all now keep in
mind at the same time Congress is trying
to put together a fifth legislative
package to deal again with that you can
either fall out a little bit 19 crisis
so trying to get Congress not only to
pass two major pieces of legislation at
the same time in about four weeks is
going to be tough just because of the
amount of work involved but that he also
tried to get Democrats and Republicans
to agree on these two major issues in
such a short timeline it's gonna be
incredibly difficult